[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 les invités voici
les titres
le secours populaire fête ses 50 ans
dans le département pour en parler nous
recevons aline grillon chargé de
développement
nous formons un point avec elle sur les
actions de l'association sur le
territoire et puis la parole a sévi le
kop beignon responsable du service
d'accompagnement des étudiants
handicapés à l'occasion des journées
andy fac elle se déroule du 13 au 17
mars à l'université versailles saint
quentin
le but de l'initiative sensibiliser le
public aux difficultés liées au handicap
voilà 50 ans que le secours populaire
existe dans le département à cette
occasion nous recevons donc aline griot
chargé de développement avec qui nous
allons faire un point sur les actions de
l'association sur le territoire bons
soirs comme ça alors dites moi quels
sont les actions phares sur le
territoire alors en fait le se replie
assez généraliste de solidarité nous
coup l'association c'est va faire aussi
bien la solidarité vestimentaires
alimentaires l'accès aux loisirs aux
vacances aux sports
deux accès à la santé des projets à
l'international n'ont du coup on va un
peu rayonner sur l'ensemble des besoins
du public qu'on reçoit et sur le
département
on a eu dans le cadre des 50 ans ou deux
actions phares la semaine dernière à la
verrière donc un intérêt dans pro avec
des avec des cris théâtre et puis une
soirée festive le samedi en présence de
julien lauprêtre le président et deux
parce qu laurier le secrétaire général
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de la
situation du noise sur le territoire
aujourd'hui c'est difficile alors nous
est mon on constate c'est qu'il ya de
plus je demande qu avant en fait par
rapport au public qu'on reçoit
et il ya des évolutions dans le puits
qu'on reçoit longueur en plus des pubs
hier pour recevait auparavant et qu'ils
étaient tous les familles en fête avec
des enfants larusso si on reçoit aussi
beaucoup de seniors maintenant plus de
jeunes et des travailleurs pauvres
et puis on a aussi une partie des aides
aux migrants et aux personnes qui
arrivent de l'étranger
j'imagine que au départ quand vous êtes
arrivé en 1960 à 1967 et il ya une
certaine évolution il a fallu à chaque
fois s'adapter
alors en fait il ya eu à chaque fois une
évolution et d
et des activités qui sont mises en place
au fur et à mesure des besoins et par
exemple l'aide alimentaire non plus
n'est pas arrivé dès le 2 la création de
ce qu aux pulls r ça s'est généralisé en
fait avec l'ouverture des frigos ans
dans les années 80 mais avant ça on
faisait pas de crier alimentaire comme
on peut le voir actuellement
donc il nous a enfin le naissante disent
qu'on a eu la création de la journée des
oubliés des vacances journée à la mer
pour les dents francs donc voilà donc
ces parties de l'accès aux vacances en
45 au niveau national pour se développer
autour d'eux d'autres actions la santé
le sport
voilà se permettent à tous de pouvoir
s'y retrouver pour les seniors vous avez
dû évoluer ses des personnes que vous ne
voyez pas en tant que vous n'avez pas vu
avant
quelles sont les actions qui ont été mis
en place pour par exemple alors pour les
seniors en fait en plus du led
qu'on peut pratiquer avec les d'autres
publics pour les skis et vestimentaires
et colis alimentaires on a mis en place
depuis plusieurs années à la fois des
des sorties spécifiques pour eux donc
des des guinguettes pour les seniors ou
des à 31 31 décembre festif pour eux et
aussi des séjours de vacances adaptées
donc où en fait on emmène des petits
groupes de seniors en alsace dans les
pays de la loire ou dans d'autres
endroits pour leur permettre de s'évader
un peu du quotidien pour les jeunes
travailleurs alors pour les jeunes
travailleurs mais si les deux on peut on
peut apporter habituellement et puis on
essaie de trouver des solutions avec nos
différents partenaires par exemple pour
le logement c'est si ce sont des
travailleurs pauvres qui sont dans une
situation précaire et qui se retrouvent
à habiter dans leur voiture au tout au
long de l'année on essaie de voir avec
nos partenaires sur le logement
ce que l'on peut faire votre mission est
d'autant plus importante maintenant ça
s'est développé
alors que ça s'arrange pas avec le temps
la mission a toujours été aussi
importante il ya 50 ans qu'aujourd'hui
après lé lé la mission est un peu
différent est peut être un peu
différente mais en tout cas le principe
est le même meilleur c'est surtout les
pluies qui se dit faire en fait donc du
coup on est toujours obligé de
d'accroître nos possibilités dead pourra
aider le maximum de personnes
alors dites moi comment on peut vous
aider contribuer à vous aider
alors on peut l'aider de différentes
manières
nous soutenons financièrement par un
bond de 2 à des millions d'euros si on
part en faisant du bénévolat on peut on
plus le pas avoir les moyens de donner
un don financier mais aura du temps pour
vous aider ou même les dents d'un noir
même les entreprises et les fondations
peuvent nous soutenir manière ou d'une
autre pour l'activité au quotidien par
la mise à disposition de salariés ou par
des mécénats financiers et moi quel type
d'objet
on peut donner pour contribuer à
l'armement mais j'ai des fois on n'est
pas au courant
on prend on collecte beaucoup de
matériel en fait hormis tout ce qui est
un meuble et électroménager qui peuvent
nous on peut récupérer si besoin mais
elle sait pas les hauts niveaux stockage
on a un peu d'eux on n'a pas forcément
les espaces qui sinon prendre tout en
fait
surpris les livres pour enfants les
produits d'hygiène les l'aide
alimentaire vestimentaire
voilà tout ce matériel peut peut-être
utile pour les secours de 4 et bien je
vous remercie madame hanoune graignon
fillon et vous restez sur le plateau
avec nous passe à un autre sujet nous
recevons sur le plateau civile le coq
beignon responsable du service
d'accompagnement des étudiants
handicapés à l'occasion des journées
andy fac elle se déroule du 13 au 17
mars à l'université versailles saint
quentin le but de l'initiative
sensibiliser le public aux difficultés
liées au handicap
bonsoir on sera alors pourquoi avoir mis
en place les
journée andy fac c'est une de nos
missions que de sensibiliser toute la
communauté universitaire au handicap
donc les étudiants les personnels et les
enseignants donc chaque année nous
organisons des journées de
sensibilisation ont dit qu on décape les
andy fac donc à la fac de saint-quentin
quelles sont les initiatives qui sont
mis en place pour les personnes
handicapées donc pour les étudiants
handicapés nous les accompagnons pour
qu'ils aient accès à leur enseignement
et qu'ils puissent passer lors de leur
examen à égalité des chances avec leurs
camarades donc l'une des personnes qui
les suivent toute la journée ça se passe
comment alors le service accompagnement
des étudiants handicapés peut recruter
des êtres humaines par exemple pour
l'accès aux enseignements ce sont des
étudiants qui prennent leurs notes et
qui leur donne qui donne aux autres
étudiants en situation de handicap
ça peut être aussi le recours à des
tuteurs pour de la reprise de cours
comme quand les étudiants sont empêchés
de venir ou des absences pour raisons
médicales et pour les examens nous
recrutons des secrétaires d'examens
qu'ils prennent
sous la dictée la composition des
étudiants en situation de handicap alors
l'événement c'est pour sensibiliser le
public aux différents handicaps les ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui vous malgré
tous les efforts tout est encore à faire
alors tout n'est peut-être pas encore à
faire mais il faut toujours sensibilisés
re sensibiliser et nous avons chaque
année des nouveaux étudiants des
nouveaux personnels qu'il faut aussi
sensibiliser sensibiliser aux situations
de handicap des personnels ou des
étudiants ça concerne beaucoup
d'étudiants à l'université dans notre
université nous accompagnons 160
étudiants en situation de handicap tous
handicaps confondus
mais comment s'adapter vous adapter les
locaux en fonction des élèves ont
commencé alors il ya l'accessibilité des
locaux certes mais c'est surtout
l'accessibilité des enseignements qui
sont très importants pour ces étudiants
donc comme je vous l'expliquais on peut
faire appel à des êtres humaines aussi
des aides matérielles comme
le des examens peut se passer sur
ordinateur si l'étudiant préfère
composer sur ordinateur on peut aussi
faire appel à des interprètes en langue
des signes pour des étudiants sourds ou
adapter des sujets ou des documents soit
en écriture a grandi ou en braille par
exemple alors les journées andy fac ça
se déroule du 13 au 17 mars
quels sont les journées phares même si
elles sont toutes intéressant oui alors
il va y avoir deux journées phares donc
demain mardi 14 et jeudi
ces journées donc demain nous aurons des
activités mis en place par une
association étudiante cap évasion qui
ont décidé cette année de mettre si je
puis dire en lumière le handicap visuel
avec ils vont proposer donc des parcours
en aveugle avec des cannes et paraît
franchissement d'obstacles et du ping
pong en aveugle sur des avec une table
adapté par exemple et
ils ont prévu d'adapter un cours de leur
master 2 on situ avec une situation de
handicap visuel et pour le professeur et
après pour les étudiants avec l'aide
d'une association spécialisée dans le
handicap visuel qui est valentin oui
mais la deuxième journée donc jeudi sera
consacrée au handicap moteur donc nous
allons faire des ateliers avec
l'association des paralysés de france
donc qui viendra avec des bénévoles en
fauteuil et des bénévoles valide pour
nous proposer des parcours en fauteuil
dans l'université et voir quelles sont
les difficultés pour déjà rentré dans
notre université se diriger vers
l'ascenseur prendre l'ascenseur aller en
salle de cours aller aux toilettes et
cetera
ils nous proposeront aussi des quizz sur
le handicap moteur d'accord et nous
accueillerons aussi donc
une
une personne qui nous proposera des
ateliers de self défense fauteuil
d'accord donc comment se défendre quand
on si jamais on est attaqué qu'on est en
fauteuil roulant quels sont les retours
pour finir du public que qui est là pour
être sensibilisés en tout cas qui
participent à ces animations et aussi
des personnes dites handicapées
quels sont les retours à la suite de ces
journées à chaque fois ils apprennent
des choses alors la première chose c'est
qu'il est quand même difficile d'aller
chercher le public pour leur faire
essayer nos ateliers
mais une fois qu'ils ont testé ils se
rendent compte des difficultés de leurs
camarades et ensuite ils sont
sensibilisés pour peut-être mieux les
aider et mieux les accompagner dans leur
quotidien
donc c'est déjà quelque chose de très
important et c'est pareil pour les
personnels et
les enseignants lorsqu'ils sont en face
d'un étudiant handicapé le seront
peut-être mieux le comprendre et mieux
l'accompagner très bien et bien je vous
remercie madame locog baignons merci
c'est la fin de ce set 8 des invités
merci de nous avons de nous avoir suivis
et surtout bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]